bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le résumé
du match des partages du championnat du
monde entre my knees karsten et fabiano
caruana match des partages jouer en semi
rapides c'est-à-dire à la cadence de 25
minutes plus 2 secondes par coup dans
cette première partie magnus carlsen
avec les blancs opta pour le coup c'est
4 au premier bout donc la partie
anglaise dans laquelle il avait obtenu
peut-être le meilleur avantage dans les
partis classiques dans cette position
dans laquelle les blancs avaient
sacrifié un pion ils vont récupérer
leurs pions facilement et les pions
fèves de leurs adversaires leur permet
d'obtenir un bon avantage par exemple
après tout reprend des quatre rois f7
ici il faudrait jouer le court watch un
très important pouces est pas le coutour
ed 1 qui paraît naturel pour jouer sur
le clouage du cahier mais ce cavalier
n'a pas n'est pas dans un clouage
absolue c'est à dire qu'il peut quand
même bouger parce qu'après cavalier e 5
si les blancs font tout reprend des huit
pièces cavaillé f3 échec est ici les
noirs ont un échec perpétuelle après roy
f1 quel point je check roy makaay f3
cheikh un petit piège qui avait tendu
fabiano caruana
après le court h1 les blancs conserver
un bon avantage dans l'imposition médus
carson a préféré rentrer dans une finale
deux tours qui sembla évidemment
avantageuse mais pas forcément gagnant
parce que la tour noire et active après
fou prend ici c'est chez croit fuite
tout reprend des cas à 3 717 échec
échange des tours dont des échecs pour
essayer de couper le roi adverse et
récupérer la colonne au vert
raissi cfk donc les mains ont une belle
majorité de pions du côté roy évidemment
avec les pions age 2 g iii f4e 4 contre
seulement deux pions chez les ch et les
noirs
et puis on achète et j'essaie donc la
possibilité de créer éventuellement deux
pions passé lié mais il ya quand même
leur war 2
kiki et bloque les pions et les noirs
ont aussi un pion passer de leur côté du
côté dame le pion c6 et la tour qui est
très bien placé sur la deuxième rangée
qui bloque le roi blanc
en général quand on a une cure aussi
bien placé on a toutes les chances de
faire de l' emballement objectivement
peut-être finale et nul après ses cinq
la partie continue autour des 5 c 2 h 4
les blancs essaye de faire jouer leur
majorité pour créer leurs pions que
passer ils ont appuyé en place et mais
ils en veulent un deuxième afin de faire
reculer le roi avec l'aide des deux
pions et de la tour c 4 f 5 échecs royal
6 tours c'est 5 h 5 et noir tentent de
fixer un petit peu les pions blancs ou
f1 le plan des blancs serait de venir
avec le roi pour essayer de déloger la
tour c 2 qui défend le pion ses quatre
tours c3 n'est noir vont échanger le
pion à 3 contre le pion c4 rejet de
tourcoing 3 tort france et 4 mai l'or
conserve toujours un pion passé mais le
fait que la tour blanche et bouger
permet évidemment au roi noir maintenant
de monter pour attaquer le pion aux 4
avec 3 e 5 tours c'est 7 de la part des
blancs pour attaquer le pion g7 est ici
c'était la position décisive la position
clé vraiment dans laquelle les noirs ont
fait l'erreur probablement l'erreur
décisive
mal autant bien sûr il leur restait
moins d'une minute je pense à ce moment
là à la pendule toujours avec les 10
secondes par coup bien sûr les noirs ici
devait absolument jouer le coutour à
deux échecs intermédiaire avant prendre
le pion bien sûr le rôle en serait
certainement veut y aura je crois est
maintenant seulement prendre le pion à 4
si jamais les blancs prennent le pion g7
les noirs ont la petite pointe ici
toujours un pour venir en f3 avec le roi
et obtenir un échec perpétuelle par
exemple si les blancs temps d'aller
chercher le troisième pion enfin le pion
à chaque pour avoir trois pions passé en
faisant tourner cinq là les blancs les
noirs ont le courroux f3 menace en
matant h3 et sur le courage de tours à
deux échecs forcé le roi soit descente
soit à revenir et dans ces cas-là on
pouvait répéter la position avec tours 1
avec la nulle je pense que fabiano
caruana a dû oublier le coup
intermédiaire de magnus carlsen après
reprend 1,4 qui est l'erreur le très
fort coût des blancs ici tour cet échec
qui oblige le roi a bougé et non pas
évidemment tu reprends g7 qui permet de
revenir dans la position qu'on vient de
voir qu'après tu auras deux échecs tour
cet échec le roi noir ne peut pas aller
en f3 et les obligés de prendre le pion
f5 et maintenant après d'autres projets
7 la tour blanche va venir prendre le
pion à cheval en se mettant angers saint
ex est imparable et gagner donc le pion
h5 et on sait que en finale deux pions
passé lié contre un pion passer d'eux
en face si ce pion passé n'est pas assez
avancée la position est gagnante les
blancs vont gagner relativement
facilement par la suite et vont
simplement avancer leurs pions
petit à petit je jouais quand même de
façon très précise après le roi qui
montrent le roi qui qui doit se protéger
devant ses pions parce que sinon après
le coup à deux ici les noirs ont la
menace de jouer tour h
un échec qui fait dame
mais le roi semaine angers 5 et donc est
protégé par ses pions et il va y avoir
maintenant des menaces de maths avec les
pions blancs
voilà les noirs qui ont donné le pion à
2 si jamais les noirs avaient était
revenu en g8 avec le roi l'europe lance
rémy orangis et aurait menacé made en
première partie gagnée par magnus
carlsen avec les blancs maintenant on va
regarder bien sûr la deuxième partie
cette fois fabiano caruana avait les
blancs et à rejouer le coup à quatre
comme il a joué dans toutes les parties
classiques et y eu le pouce et 5 la
sicilienne sicilienne schennikov à
nouveau avec le coup cavaillé des cinq
au septième coupe magnus carlsen à
rejouer son coût cavaliers hausse est
donc au huitième coup on atterrit dans
cette position dans laquelle les blancs
avaient quand même une position avec un
petit avantage relativement agréable
mais très curieusement peut-être fabiano
caruana a voulais absolument jouer pour
nice et attire et voulait absolument
gagner cette partie évidemment elle joue
un peu trop agressif et aurait dû
tranquillement au 21e coût de cette
partie jouée au lieu du pouce et 5
le petit rock évidemment un petit rock
protéger son roi va mener la tour eiffel
tout simplement ça c'est classique et
sur petit rôle des noirs peut-être joué
le coup cavaliers bay 5-1 en vue de
faire pression sur le pion des six on
pourra essayer de jouer ses cinq plus
tard
évidemment c'est le plan pour créer
créer un pion passé
en d5 et ensuite l'avancé mais on n'a
pas besoin de se presser le coup ces
cinq jouer au 21e coût est trop et trop
rapide
il fallait mieux rocqué avant n'est noir
rock tranquillement et laisse ses pions
et ici aussi les noirs font peut-être
pas le meilleur coup il aurait quand
même dû prendre le pion des 6 et ensuite
faire le rock
ils ont préféré joué ces six c'est vrai
que c'est assez thématiques 1 ce genre
de pousser le pion mais là ça va se
retourner contre lui et parce que le roi
blanc grèce est restée au centre indique
que s'il avait déjà rockets serait
probablement été un bon coup mais là les
noirs les noirs vont pouvoir prendre
l'initiative avec des princes et 6 des
procès six tours fc 8 tout de suite le
pian c6 est attaqué dams et 4 pour le
défendre alors le coup le coup qui a
aidé des cinq qui avait l'air bon s'il
est blanc aéro qu'est justement ce qu'il
ou qu'elle ait cinq jours a été bon là
le problème du bouquet des singles c'est
qu'il ya le coût d'un me 4 qui est très
embêtant attaquons la tourache 1 et le
quai et des 5
donc ça va pas du tout les blancs sont
dans l'obligation donc le jeune homme
ses cadres pour défendre le pion mais
bon je le joli coup food et 8 pour
bloquer le plan 6,6 et éventuellement
par la suite ramené le fou en a cinq
cavaillé des cinq a été joué que 4 un
bon coup aussi puisque ça va libérer la
15e 5 pour lequel j 6 maintenant toutes
les pièces noires qui commencent à
s'activer sur les bonnes cases
là il fallait il était temps avec les
blancs d'empêcher cette menace en jouant
probablement le coup food et 4 pour
essayer de prendre ce cavalier qui
arrivant aux cinq les blancs aux jouets
c7 probablement l'erreur décisif puisque
après fou prend ses sept bien jouer
cavalier prend ses sept cavaliers eu
cinq attaquants la dame bien de temps
donc avec le cavalier ici il y avait
déjà plus beaucoup pour les blancs la
dame devait bouger bon il n'a pas bougé
dans la
partie hélas il a joué le coup on va
voir rapidement cavaillé des cinq en
pensant qu'il y avait des menaces
tactique grâce à la fourchette en hausse
est donc si les loups apprennent la dame
en c4 il y aurait la fourchette
cavaliers ou cet échec au récupère la
dame et c'était compliqué mais il a
oublié tout simplement le que les noirs
pouvaient bouger le roi meyers a été
jouée très rapidement 3 h 7
et là il y avait plus de couler blanc
abandonné le seul coup après le 27e ou
des noirs qui avait eu cinq c'était
d'amd 5 mai il y avait le bon coup tour
à des huit tout simplement qu'ils
étaient très très gênant pour les blancs
le seul coup probablement maintenant
c'est de faire le petit rock et le
coutour français 7 permet de récupérer
tout simplement la pièce puisque il ya
la menace à la découverte cavaliers f3
échec et après peut-être dame prend des
six tours prend c'est un d'un premier 8
échecs tour ses huit dames bessette les
bleus ont encore des petites chances de
tenir mais la position noir est quand
même très largement supérieure avec leur
pièce très active ici donc fabiano
caruana qui qui a voulu aller un peu
trop 8 dans ce dans cette partie qui
finalement fini par perdre voilà il va
être obligé de gagner la troisième
partie pour essayer de continuer dans ce
match on va tout de suite voir cette
troisième partie donc marc nous car
scène avec les blancs magnus carlsen qui
a choisi cette fois de jeu locaux 4
évidemment si fabiano caruana jouer ça
petrov habituel on bat les blancs
auraient pu facilement faire une partie
nulle ce qui aurait suffi pour le gain
du match donc fabiano caruana a essayé
de gelée sicilienne c'était bien joué
il obtient mois il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup des changes il obtient cette
position en finale dames et cavaliers
contre dame est fou le couple d'amis
cavaliers un tout petit peu supérieur à
demi fou en général le problème c'est
que les blancs ici ont aussi un bon
piont passé soutenu cheval dame
donc ça va être quand même compliqué
pour les noirs de faire quelque chose
probablement le coup objectif le
meilleur c'était cavaliers ces deux dans
cette position pour attaquer la dame et
il y avait une grande force et pour les
blancs qui aboutissait certainement à
une nulle
après ces cinq dames d un échec d'hommes
j'ai un dame e2c 6 voilà le pion qui
continue à avancer tout simplement dames
et cavaliers qui tente de créer des
menaces après damas avec donc pour
empêcher le pion d'avancé ans et 7 d'un
v6 pour jouer ces sept cavaliers des 4
c'est cette voie là les noirs peuvent
plus empêcher le pion canada donc ils
sont obligés de trouver des menaces mais
après deux échecs rouages de dames 5
échecs ya rien de mieux que l'échec
perpétuelle look évidemment fabiano
caruana n'est pas rentrer là-dedans il a
tenté le coup 40 cavaliers ou six les
blancs en profite pour avancer leurs
pions en jambes et 4 un bon coup puisque
d'un premier 4 n'est pas possible à
cause du cavalier aussi ceux qui
seraient pas protégées dont kobe 4 qui
permet d'avancer le pied en c5 est ici
le coup naturel qui auraient dû être
joués aussi qu'elle allait f4 aboutissez
à l'annuelle après ses cinq dames d un
échec rouages de probablement g5 pour
essayer de protéger le cavalier et
avancer les pions pour recréer une
attaque le problème c'est que les blancs
ont un échec perpétuelle peut même en
gendarme cet échec 3 et 6 2
échec le roi noir ne peut pas se
protéger il n'y a pas assez de
protection donc fabiano caruana à tenter
autre chose il a joué cavalier g5 qui
est objectivement pas un bon coup mais
il ne pouvait pas faire un nul il
fallait absolument qu'ils jouent pour le
gabon qu'il a pris des risques
après ces cinq dames et 6 et 6 le plus
on avance tout droit adam k way 6 pour
le bloquer à 4 voilà un deuxième pion
qui va arriver pour aider son son
homologue le pion les deux pions passé
sont inarrêtables et les pièces noires
ne pourront plus créer de menaces sur le
roi de la fin c'était kbc cette dame f4
qui avait eu 6 d'indécis s'il aurait
même pu répéter les coups mais
maintenant les blondes savent qu'ils
vont gagner la partie donc qu'il joue
pour gagner d'amara échec watch deux
quais veille des quatre c'est cette dame
ces trois dames c5 un très bon coup le
cavalier ne peut pas rattraper le pion
donc les blancs propose échange des
dames maintenant les noirs vont tenter
avec dame et cavaliers d'obtenir quelque
chose d'à me 3 déjà ici d'un prend des
quatre ans était possible d'ailleurs au
coude avant aussi mais les melons
préfère faire une deuxième dame
ces huit dames f4 dame g4 est évidemment
avec deux dames les noirs vont
abandonner et avait aucune possibilité
pour eux de créer quelques menaces que
ce soit donc troisième victoire pour
manu ce qu'arsène objectivement
évidemment cette partie aurait dû se
termine par un nul mais fabienne leclerc
rona devait absolument gagner pour
essayer de sauver le match en espérant
aussi gagner la quatrième partie donc
3-0 pour manu ce qu'arsène qui donc
garde son titre de champion du monde
merci à tous d'avoir suivi ces résumés
et jeu
vous dis à bientôt sur check point com